ce soir des révélations troublantes sur
l'herbicide le plus utilisé dans le
monde le round up et son ingrédient
actif le glyphosate
c'est la façon dont cinq femmes on
applique sur la potion magique une
potion magique classées cancérigènes
probables et qui a pourtant été
approuvée à nouveau par santé canada
pour 15
monsanto a payé plus de 289 millions de
dollars un jardinier américain atteint
d'un cancer c'est bien sûr inédit est-ce
que je vous rires ils ont dit
probablement pas mais oui sa voiture
enjoy
c'est lourd et chaque fois que ça
revient qui me demande pourquoi moi mais
la puissante monsanto qui fabriquent
leur hold-up dit qu'il n'y a aucun
danger
étude à l'appui mais quelles études mais
ajoute fait par monsanto qui montrent un
risque réel on se fait enterrer et n'ont
jamais été divulgués aux autorités notre
équipe s'est plongé dans lemon santo
peppers des documents demeurer secret
jusqu'à tout récemment qui révèle
notamment le rôle joué par une
entreprise canadienne dans la défense du
rwanda
ce monstre fait est que les organismes
de réglementation conçu que nous
protégions ont échoué les audaces
bienvenue à enquête
[Musique]
en structurant manque vraiment
je serais resté mais ça a été impossible
nous savons
ce n'est jamais facile pour allen lequel
est de revenir aux chutes niagara
c'est un endroit où elle a travaillé
pendant presque vingt ans par goldman
s'il ya des bons et des mauvais
souvenirs
drizzt d'une certaine manière j'ai des
sentiments partagés trad
max fait on sait qu'en 2002 elle a été
diagnostiquée avec un cancer et elle se
demande maintenant s'il est lié au rand
hop indé herbicides auquel elle a été
exposée pendant plusieurs années
vous voyez ces airbus là bas il vaporise
et jusqu'à là aussi en marchant je
pouvais goûter
j'en avais sur mes vêtements si elle
soupçonne le roundup c'est qu'il est
aujourd'hui au coeur d'une immense
controverse
monsanto qui le fabrique depuis 40 ans
vient d'être condamné aux états unis
pour avoir caché des liens possibles
avec le cancer
non seulement il savait que sa cause le
cancer mais ils sont allé jusqu'à
attaquer le scientifique qui avait des
inquiétudes et je le dis sans détour
jusqu'à commettre de la fraude
scientifique
on croise qu'ils nous disent et ensuite
on apprend qu'ils nous ont trahis qu'ils
ont caché la vérité
des milliers de gens comme verlaine
cherche la vérité
depuis que des documents internes de
monsanto ont été rendus publics
révélant des secrets bien gardés des
secrets dont les pistes mènent jusqu ici
chez nous et jusqu'à d'anciens
fonctionnaires de santé canada
quand le rendent up arrivent sur le
marché au milieu des années 70 c'est une
révolution
[Musique]
l'herbicide fabriqué par monsanto su
presque toutes les plantes avec lesquels
ils entrent en contact sauf celles qui
seront programmés génétiquement pour y
résister
son ingrédient un miracle et le
glyphosate
notre histoire commence lorsque le
roundup est commercialisé au canada en
c'est l'année où un certain jean
monnereau commence à gravir les échelons
à santé canada au bureau de l'innocuité
des produits chimiques
on le voit ici commenté les dangers du
mercure sur les zones de sybille grippe
jusqu'à la direction générale des
aliments puis il quitte santé canada
c'est l'époque où le gouvernement sous
traitent de plus en plus au privé en
1985 monroe fonde avec dans ses
collègues une entreprise de consultants
en toxicologique tox
retenez ce nom il était important pour
la suite de l'histoire
le destin de yên monroe va croiser et
éventuellement celui de lnb tennis mais
n'allons pas trop vite l'année après que
chemtox voit le jour ellen commence à
travailler au parc provincial des chutes
niagara
d'abord comme chauffeur de navettes
avant de devenir superviseur du service
j'adorais ce que j'adorais rencontrer
des gens de partout dans le monde
ils paient des milliers de dollars pour
venir ici et j aurai accès tous les
jours hélène remarque que lors de
l'entrée du parc
un employé vaporise des pesticides 10
angle dangereux en bordure des trottoirs
et du stationnement
il portait un survêtement blanc des
bottes de caoutchouc des gants un masque
et un cap champ sur sa tête
il était protégé mais pas moi c'est
inquiète parce que je pouvais y goûter
un jour l'une de ses collègues étaient
disposés au point de devoir rentrer chez
elle qu'elle songe aussi aux visiteurs y
avait des enfants des adultes
tout le monde y est exposé faire 3 qui
est passé ça reste dans l'air extérieur
et la navy son représentant en santé
sécurité mais l'épandage se poursuit
ps ça a continué pendant des années tout
le temps que j étais chaque printemps
chaque été hélène estime qu'elles
pourraient avoir été exposés à des
produits comme le roundup
une cinquantaine de fois entre temps les
affaires semble bien aller à toronto
pour qu'une taxe est lancée
fonctionnaires ian monroe il met son
expérience au service de l'industrie et
pas n'importe laquelle celle du tabac on
est quelques années avant que le
scandale n'éclate
quand on apprendra que l'industrie a
longtemps caché les études sur les
risques associés au tabac à jane's un
projet secret un produit sans fumée
qu'ils espèrent soustraire à la loi
canadienne sur les aliments et drogues
et pour approcher santé canada il fait
appel à une monroe
ces documents confirment que ian monroe
a eu de rencontre confidentielle avec
son ancien patron et ami personnel
le sous-ministre adjoint de l'époque
pour discuter d'une extension sur la
manière de rapporter le taux de goudron
de sa nouvelle cigarette
le projet a échoué quand hawks a reçu
plusieurs contrats des gouvernements
fédéral et provinciaux et se trouvait au
coeur de plusieurs controverses une mare
bercenay qui est apparu dans un cours
d'eau maison 1998 chemtox est embauché
pour évaluer les risques à la santé
posés par 700 mille tonnes de boues
toxiques provenant d'une usine de
charbon désaffectée à sydney en
nouvelle-écosse quand hawks conclut
qu'il n'y a aucun risque pour la santé
humaine
une conclusion qui a eu l'effet d'une
bombe auprès des résidents de la rue
frédéric qui ont quitté la réunion en
trombe
le rapport de cannes tox sera siderno
critiquée par d'autres experts puis en
1999 pour le projet d'expansion de
lusine de hurling où c'était pile et
chemtox la chef du nouveau parti
démocratique elizabeth weir affirme que
le gouvernement du nouveau brunswick a
eu tort de donner carte blanche à un
baigneur sur la foi du rapport favorable
de la société carbox de halifax une
société dite elle qui a la réputation de
favoriser l'entreprise sur l'intérêt
public chemtox acquiert une réputation
internationale en produisant des
évaluations de risques pour l'industrie
des plastiques du chlore des additifs
alimentaires des pesticides et bientôt
pour monsanto
cela aura d'importantes répercussions
entre autres pour l ennemi sioniste dont
la vie va bientôt prendre un tournant
inattendu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en 2018
la californie a été le théâtre d'une
bataille judiciaire dont l'issue a eu
l'effet d'une bombe
plus de 289 millions de dollars un
jardinier américain atteint d'un cancer
c'est bien sûr imedi les dommages ont
été réduits à 78 millions monsanto
devenu veilleux doit maintenant se
défendre des allégations 7 lors du
procès des allégations contenues dans
des documents internes que brent with no
l'avocat du demandeur est parvenu à
faire déclassifiés lemon santo peppers
comme on les appelle révèle selon lui
comme monsanto a pesé pour semer le
doute sur la science entourant son
produit de dette
le rand c'est une des stratégies
emprunté à l'industrie du tabac à
manipuler la science pour discréditer la
bonne science pour semer le doute
nous ne sommes tous très télé jusqu'à
cacher des études michao des études
faites par monsanto qui montrent un
risque réel ont été enterrés et n'ont
jamais été divulgués aux autorités ou à
la communauté scientifique les
désherbant roundup sont une des méthodes
les plus efficaces pour nettoyer votre
jardin ou vos champs mais quand étiez de
la substance active principal
me faisais tu es tu sais la fin des
années 90 quelques études indépendantes
signal de possibles effets toxiques du
glyphosate et durant dope monsanto fait
appel à un chercheur britannique de
renault james peries pour se pencher sur
ces recherches inquiétante
le docteur perry arrive à la conclusion
que le glyphosate et le roundup où le
potentiel d'être génotoxique et causé
des dommages associés au cancer
il propose de faire des études
supplémentaires réaction du responsable
de l'évaluation de la sécurité des
produits chez monsanto
nous voulons former quelqu'un qui pourra
influencer les autorités quand ces
questions de génotoxicité vont surgir
perry n'a pas l'air d'être cette
personne c'est à tort la réaction de
monsanto
on le voit dans les documents c'est de
dire on ne fera pas ses études
cet homme n'est pas notre porte parole
les conclusions du docteur paris n'ont
jamais été soumis aux autorités
américaines
ce qui constitue une violation ni à
santé canada
mon sens tout répond que ses propres
scientifiques ont plus tard fait la
plupart des études recommandé par le
docteur perry et publier les résultats
ils n'ont pas trouvé d'effet génotoxique
sous des conditions d'exposition adéquat
est possible de savoir ce que le docteur
perry en pense il est décédé juste après
l'épisode du docteur perry un autre
problème se manifeste à l'horizon une
étude auprès d'agriculteurs canadien
signal ollier autre le glyphosate est
cette fois un type particulier de cancer
le lymphome non-hodgkinien un employé de
monsanto écrit nous allons commencer à
travailler là dessus
au cas où les choses ne changent pas et
que l'article attire l'attention des
médias et il dit de l'étude canadienne
que la qualité des données n'est pas
très bonne
peut-être pas très bonnes pour monsanto
mais john meglen l'un des principaux
auteurs de cette étude est aujourd'hui
permis les plus respectés au pays
il est scientifique en chef de la santé
publique de l'ontario
oui oui nous avons été surpris parce
qu'au départ sur le plan scientifique
on avait aucun soupçon que le glyphosate
pouvait avoir un lien avec ce type de
cancer mais une fois qu'on l'a découvert
on se devait de le rapporter
quand l'article canadiens et publiée
monsanto se réjouit que le mot
glyphosate n'apparaissent pas dans le
résumé un grand pas en avant
écrit la toxicologue en chef de monsanto
ça évite qu'ils soient repérable dans
les journaux scientifiques
monsanto conteste toujours la validité
de l'étude canadienne le monde
scientifique a réagi en s'intéressant à
la question est dans les années
suivantes d'autres études semblables à
la nôtre ont rapporté les mêmes
résultats
au cours des années suivantes monsanto
collabore aussi avec d'éminents
chercheurs pour faire avancer la
recherche sur le glyphosate
mais il y a un mot qui revient dans les
moines saintot peppers et qui soulève
des doutes sur certains de ces travaux
le ghostwriting une pratique qui
consiste à écrire un article en partie
ou en totalité et à en donner la
paternité à d'autres experts qui semble
plus crédible ou indépendante même
moment où ces études sont publiées
monsanto fabrique des études qui disent
le contraire
l'une de ces études deviendra la
référence selon monsanto
elle est publiée en 2000 elle conclut
que le roundup ne pose aucun risque pour
la santé humaine
cette publication est signée par trois
chercheurs williams kroes et monroe ian
monroe et l'ancien fonctionnaire de
santé canada devenu président de kent
offs le plus troublant et cette remarque
d'un des cadres de monsanto qui suggère
de coûts écrire certaines publications
les coûts serait plus raisonnable en
rédigeant nous-mêmes et des chercheurs
ne ferait que réviser et signé pour ici
dire
rappelez vous c'est ce que nous avions
fait avec williams kroes et monroe en
soyons clairs sur ce qui est vraiment
chemtox ce n'est pas un groupe de
chercheurs indépendants offrant une
opinion scientifique
ils fournissent le pognon souhaité par
l'industrie d'allende suédois l'auteur
principal de l'étude de l'expert
américain gary williams assure que ce
n'est pas le cas monsanto a acheté
depuis par b1 nie catégoriquement ces
allégations souligne que les auteurs ont
divulgué en toute bonne foi avoir
bénéficié de l'important soutien
scientifique du fabricant au procès la
juge était sensible de cet argument sous
serment un des cadres a expliqué avoir
apporté des changements mineurs
par souci de cartes et ce n'est pas
écrit sur un pépin on a fabriqué ces
études
ce sont ses propres mots
cet autre courriel à cannes tox montre
tout de même que monsanto s'est gardé le
dernier mot je vais réviser le manuscrit
final avant d'envoyer à l'éditeur dit un
employé de monsanto
puis dans un message privé à une
collègue canucks pense que j'allais
vraiment leur laisser faire les
révisions finales
supervision
[Musique]
en 2002 ça fait plus de 15 ans que
hélène mécanisme travail au parc des
chutes niagara et sa santé vient
brusquement de se détériorer
elle apprend qu'elle est atteinte de
type rare de cancer un lymphome non
hodgkinien
le choc est terrible au souviens c'est
comme si on m'avait assommer avec un
marteau j'étais si bouleversée que j'ai
dû laisser ma voiture à l'hôpital et
demandé à mon mari de venir me chercher
je ne pouvais pas conduire
je vomissais j'étais sous le choc
allez à l'hôpital en pensant avoir la
grippe et vous apprenez que c'est le
cancer les médecins ignorent pourquoi
gélinas cancer elle entreprend un
traitement de chimiothérapie sauva
reçoit nice stadium
c'est à ce moment que j'ai commencé un
traitement
je ne connais pas le nom mais ils
l'appellent le diable rouge et roche
c'est un traitement très dur pour tuer
les cellules de croissance elle doit
éventuellement cessé de travailler
la chimiothérapie cause un brouillard
ford faisait beaucoup d'erreurs si on ne
peut plus travailler au mieux parti
la maladie revient d'une deuxième fois
en 2010 et encore une fois elle n aura
droit à une rémission
peu après à des milliers de kilomètres
de là près de san francisco
un jardinier est sur le point de devenir
un cauchemar pour monsanto
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le nom de dwayne johnson qu'on voit ici
lors d'un bref passage à toronto a fait
le tour du monde depuis qu'il a remporté
sa bataille judiciaire contre le
fabricant du rand hop aux états unis
mais ce n'est rien à côté du combat que
l'homme de 47 ans aussi rappeur et ses
heures mènent contre le cancer
[Musique]
leigh johnson est aux prises avec un
lymphome non hodgkinien un cancer qui se
manifeste dans son cas par de
douloureuses lésions sur la peau sa
maladie est au coeur du litige qui
l'oppose au géant de l'agrochimie
je ne parle jamais de monsanto
d'habitude je ne prononce même pas ce
nom parce que la science
ce n'est pas ma spécialité tout ce que
je sais c'est qu'un jury a vu la preuve
et a tiré ses conclusions
son cancer était paru quand il était
responsable de l'entretien paysager de
plusieurs écoles de la région de san
francisco
il lui arrivait de vaporiser des
centaines de litres de désherbant par
jour on lui avait dit que le produit
était sans danger
l'instructeur cétacés avec nous il a dit
qu'on pouvait en voir nancy n'est pas
dangereux leigh johnson ne prend aucun
risque
mais malgré ces précautions une grande
quantité de produits s'est répandu sous
ses vêtements protection lors d'un bris
d'équipement puis des lésions sont
apparus sur sa peau le cancer a été
confirmé en 2014 ma réaction ça a été
est-ce que je en rire l essai ou a eu
chez nous on dit probablement pas mais
oui ça pourrait être très dur à entendre
parce qu'il n'y a pas vraiment de
remèdes leigh johnson s'est tournée vers
le service à la clientèle de monsanto
sur le premier appel a lieu en novembre
juste après le diagnostic de cancer il
demande à monsanto est ce que c'est pour
être lié au roundup suis curieux de
savoir ce que j'ai parce que je n'ai
jamais exposé à rien d'autre on prend
les informations et on lui dit on vous
rappelle personne ne rappelle
l'appel de leigh johnson restent sans
réponse à l'automne 2014
monsanto un problème plus urgent des
cadres dans nos familles envoient un
courriel à des collègues
ce que nous avions craint vient
d'arriver le glyphosate fera l'objet
d'une analyse par le centre
international de recherche sur le cancer
ces craintes se concrétise en mars 2015
l' agence de l'eau ms conclu que le
glyphosate est un cancérigène probable
effet en passant en revue toute la
littérature scientifique publiée dans le
monde dans de nombreux domaines
différents
le canadien john médoc lune dont les
travaux avaient été mises en doute par
monsanto il ya 20 ans fait partie du
groupe d'experts choisis par le comité
international pour se pencher sur le
danger du glyphosate la classification
du comité international étaient fondées
sur des preuves
le processus la pratiquent la rigueur
c'était solide comme le roc
monsanto est en désaccord total
la décision du fabricant contredit la
position des autorités réglementaires
dans le monde
ils réclament une rétractation et
qualifie la décision du comité de
biaiser et de sciences poubelle
l'expression science poubelle a été
créée par l'industrie du tabac pour
tenter de discréditer les données
scientifiques suggérant que le tabagisme
est la fumée secondaire était une cause
de cancer
ça m'a presque fait rire je me suis dit
les voilà qui recommence
la décision du comité international fait
rapidement l'objet de protestations dans
la presse dans les cercles
universitaires et sur les réseaux
sociaux dans les coulisses monsanto
aurait soigneusement orchestré la
réplique le clan remettre en question la
pertinence du comité en faisant publier
des articles qui le contredisent des
employés d'un médecin tôt suggère de les
écrire eux-mêmes pour réduire les coûts
rapidement 15 experts canadiens
américains et européens signent une
série d'articles et affirment
unanimement que le glyphosate n'est pas
dangereux ils se présentent tous comme
indépendants bien que 12 des 15 admet
avoir été consultant pour monsanto dans
le passé il y avait quelque chose de
frappant dans le moment et dans
l'intensité de ce tollé monsanto avait
confié le projet à une firme de
consultants de l'ontario intertek et
derniers détails
intertek était auparavant connue sous le
nom de call box la même compagnie de
l'ancien fonctionnaire de santé canada
ils m'ont nouveau boxe a évolué pour
devenir une société appelée intertek
dès que le comité international a
classic glyphosate comme cancérigène
probable pour l'homme la première chose
qu'ils ont faite c'est de payer intertek
pour faire une revue scientifique
prétendument aidé pendant cinq ou six
articles qui ont en fait été
soigneusement sculpté contrôler et en
partie écrit par des employés de monde
soit oralement le rôle d'un terreau tech
et nébuleux
la firme a été retenu est payé par
monsanto
la présence de cet intermédiaire entre
la compagnie et les chercheurs peut
donner l'impression qu'ils sont
indépendants
mais comment savoir que ce soit
orchestrée par l'industrie suggèrent que
ce n'est pas indépendant qu'une firme
créée ou organisent ces publications
ce n'est pas la manière dont les
scientifiques travaillent on fait nos
propres travaux voici des échanges de
courriels entre monsanto et intertek
la compagnie a suivi attentivement
l'évolution de plusieurs des articles 6
janvier 2016
merci pour la mise à jour sur les
expérimentations animales et le chapitre
de résumer j'avais déjà écrit un
brouillon d'introduction christ décider
qui en sera l'auteur toi ou guéris
toujours le 6 janvier au sujet d'un des
articles
il faut parler de la version finale
lorsque ce n'est pas exactement ce à
quoi je m'attendais 13 janvier voici mes
propositions de changement 8 février et
hairtech s'il te plait je te coup d'oeil
à ce qu'il ya de neuf de la part du
groupe
épidémiologie le lendemain monsanto
répond ok j'ai lu tous les documents et
indiquer ce que je crois pu rester et ce
qui peut être enlevé en dépit de cela
les auteurs des articles ont tous
affirmé dans leurs déclarations
d'intérêts qu'aucun employé de monsanto
n'a révisé leur manuscrit avant
publication et les x
c'est un mensonge en raison du travail
que nous avons fait le journal qui les a
publiées a admis qu'il y a eu des
erreurs
les auteurs ont depuis corrigé leurs
déclarations d'intérêts il précise que
trois des articles ont subi des
changements mineurs
et que monsanto n'a pas influencé leurs
conclusions de panélistes ont toutefois
dû admettre avoir été payés directement
par le fabricant pour leur contribution
tous ont présenté des excuses ce n'était
pas des études scientifiques mais plutôt
une opinion un point de vue de ces
jeunes n'est pas étonnant d'apprendre
qu'ils ont été influencées par
l'industrie
ck je mettrais un grand drapeau rouge
sur la qualité et l'intégrité de ses
publications
quelques jours après que le glyphosate
est classé cancérigène probable leigh
johnson subite un deuxième bris
d'équipement encore une fois il est
inondé et kg et il rappelle la compagnie
deux semaines après que le glyphosate
soient classées cancérigènes probables
il y rappelle qu'il inquiète son cancer
empire et lui disent qu'ils vont le
rappeler mais ne le font pas alors ils
traversent une autre saison de
vaporisation jusqu'en 2016
et pendant cette période le cancer qui
était contrôlable devient une sentence
de mort
au procès de leigh johnson le jury a
tranché en sa faveur
il a conclu que le roundup peut causer
le lymphome non hodgkinien qu'il a été
un facteur substantiel dans celui de lee
johnson et que monsanto n'a pas informé
le public des dangers de son produit
malgré les objections de monsanto la
juge a maintenu le verdict monsanto fait
appel de la décision et maintient
qu'elle ne reflète pas l'état de la
science ce qui attend les johnson ne lui
fait plus peur
tout le monde doit mourir un jour
on dit que la shlmr mille fois qu'un
soldat nous l'heure qu'une fois mais je
n'ai pas peur si je dois mourir
au moins je mourrai pour quelque chose
ni internet ni monson tous nos souhaité
répondre à nos questions
le fabricant nous a évité à nous tourner
vers santé canada
après la pause sur quoi s'appuient santé
canada pour approuver le before that
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai commencé très jeune fille juste
parce que j'aime
comme on pourrait le faire michel zilina
est fermier de sixième génération
s'affirme c'est ans sur 1200 acres dans
le comté de maskinongé et comme la vaste
majorité des producteurs au pays
il utilise les herbicides à base de
glyphosate sur son maïs c'est la façon
dont cinq fois on applique ça ils
devraient dispendieux il l'est plus la
potion magique on utilise ce petit plant
mais la magie du glyphosate suscite
maintenant des inquiétudes
les agriculteurs sont parmi les plus
exposés et sont aussi malgré eux projeté
au coeur du débat
doublement sensibiliser parce que j'ai
un père qui est décédé d'un cancer est
beaucoup trop jeune puis dans son
entourage jeudi à 5 minutes de
l'automobile d'ici je nettoie aux cartes
mais même un exemple tout le stade du
même house qui alors donc ces quads
le canada a été le premier pays
industrialisé à renouveler
l'homologation du glyphosate après sa
classification comme cancérigènes
probables en disant se baser sur la
science ici au québec quelques
chercheurs s'intéressent au glyphosate
élise caron beaudoin a étudié une enzyme
du corps humain et sa sensibilité à
l'exposition de certains pesticides
elle a testé le glyphosate seul et si
que le rwanda dans la co culture qui
était exposée aux grandes heures
on avait vraiment une perturbation de
l'activité de l'aromatase puis une
perturbation 6 de la production de
plusieurs hormones des estrogènes entre
autres
ces résultats sont préliminaires mais
d'autres études dans le monde ont obtenu
des résultats semblables
on sait aussi qu'une perturbation de la
production d'oestrogènes s'est associé à
des problèmes de santé
on peut penser à des maladies qu'on
appelle hormono dépendantes comme le
cancer du sein
la chercheure a obtenu ces résultats
seulement avec le roundup sauf qu'au
canada on n'évalue pas le rende pour la
centaine d'autres formulations
commerciale qui lui ressemble
on s'en tient à l'ingrédient principal
le glyphosate les résultats qui doivent
être transmis ne concerne que
l'ingrédient actif mais dans la réalité
les ingrédients actifs sont jamais
utilisées tout seul sont toujours
utilisés en formulation donc dans la
réglementation les formulations sont pas
prises en considération et on peut se
poser la question si en fait la
réglementation est basée en fait sur
toutes les données toxicologiques
pertinente
santé canada a renouvelé l'approbation
du glyphosate pour 15 ans depuis huit à
vis de position formelle ont été
déposées par des universitaires des
médecins et des groupes environnementaux
dont équiterre
[Musique]
ce soir au téléjournal monsanto dans la
mire de santé canada des centaines
d'études sur l'herbe issus des
enveloppes seront revus ces études là
que sites santé canada lorsqu'il parle
de cet enjeu du cancer en lien avec le
glyphosate
santé canada a rejeté toutes les
objections n'y trouvant aucun fondement
scientifique
malgré les révélations contenues dans
lemon santo peppers le ministère
considère toujours que le glyphosate ne
pose aucun risque à la santé ou à
l'environnement aux seuils actuels
d'exposition
il maintient la décision originale le
ministère s'appuie entre autres sur 118
études toxicologiques dont 111 sont
confidentielles et proviennent de
monsanto sous le sceau du secret
commercial
il admet que les trois quarts de ces
études sur la santé proviennent de
l'industrie
au contraire le centre international de
recherche sur le cancer c'est puis
uniquement sur des recherches publiées
et les visées par les pairs la décision
finale repose sur un petit nombre
d'études pour lesquels il était clair
qu'elle avait de bonnes mesures une
bonne conception une bonne analyse
santé canada a aussi rejeté l'option de
soumettre le problème à un comité
d'experts indépendants en janvier
l'avocat américain pratt whitney a
affronté le froid polaire de la capitale
nationale pour venir rencontrer des
parlementaires à ottawa
il y deux nous leur dire que santé
canada
ces fausses routes dès la date à kribi
les données n'ont pas été révisés de
manière indépendante
alors on ne sait pas vraiment sur quoi
se basent leur jugement scientifique et
je crois que c'est problématique quand
il s'agit de santé publique
quelque chose qui est probablement
cancérigènes pas n'est pas d'hésitation
pour moi si c'est probablement
cancérigènes déjà là ya un souci à ce
jour si l'innocuité du glyphosate a
donné lieu à des débats houleux en
particulier toutes les agences
réglementaires dans le monde continuent
de l'approuver malgré la décision du
centre international de recherche sur le
cancer
c'est quand même un comité qui est qui
formé d'experts dans le domaine ya assez
d'études qui nous permettent de dire 20
peut-être on devrait se pencher un peu
plus là dessus pas concrétisées principe
de précaution dans scolaire au canada
l'industrie n'est pas rester sans rien
faire dans ce courriel provenant de
monsanto
on apprend que le lobby canadien a
suggéré à ses membres d'écrire au
gouvernement pour lui demander de
retirer son financement ou comité
international de recherche sur le cancer
c'est inquiétant et ça ne fait pas
avancer la science ça n'améliore pas la
santé publique et ça n'a rien à voir
avec et aider à nourrir la planète ce
qui devrait être l'objectif de la
compagnie
on ne sait pas si l'industrie canadienne
a mis sa menace à exécution
mais rien de cela ne rassure michel
zilina que beaucoup de produits de même
plusieurs années après sa soeur au
piquet on a commencé on a produit les
thés en vue sur le marché parce que il
met toute sa confiance en santé canada
tout ce qu'on veut c'est de fournir des
aliments de qualité puis bien faire les
choses puis amenés à se protéger comme
producteur aussi le ministère a accordé
une entrevue à nos collègues de la
semaine verte et de l'épicerie mais a
décliné la demande d' enquête il dit
trouver déconcertante
l'affirmation au sujet de référence
inadéquate ou trompeuses dont certains
articles d'intertek et celui de caen tox
et bien que ces publications soient dans
sa liste de référence et qui les sites
dans sa réponse le ministère affirme
qu'elles n'ont eu aucune incidence sur
sa décision
au retour le destin des laines va
croiser celui du docteur moreau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cet autre procès contre monsanto sont
prévues cette année aux états unis et
des milliers d'autres sont en attente la
sphère johnson n'est pas terminée la
cour a accepté d'entendre rapidement
l'appel du fabricant banlieue mais qu
importe l'issue les gentilles et
satisfait les avocats m'ont dit les
procédures d'appel vont durer des années
peut-être même plus longtemps que toi tu
ne seras plus là mais au moins tu fais
quelque chose de bon pour ta famille ça
m'aide à me sentir bien
[Musique]
2018 n'a pas été une bonne année pour l
ennemi tennis le cancer est revenu une
troisième fois sa contrôler ma vie mais
c'est lourd et chaque fois que ça
revient je me demande pourquoi moi mais
il y en eu raison qu'on connaît son nom
hélène vient rencontrer l'oncologue pour
obtenir les résultats de ces derniers
tests elle veut savoir ce qui l'attend
ne sera probablement jamais les
certitudes de ce qui a causé son cancer
c'est seulement au fil du temps que ses
soupçons se sont portés sur ses
multiples expositions au roundup sauvage
je me suis tourné vers la commission de
la sécurité professionnelle mais elle a
rejeté ma demande en disant que la
preuve scientifique n'est pas suffisante
avec le lymphome non hodgkinien
la commission des accidents du travail
de l'ontario a pris cette décision avant
que le glyphosate ne soit classé
cancérigène probable
elle a justifié son refus en s'appuyant
entre autres sur une importante
publication qui conclut que le
glyphosate n'est ni carcinogènes n'est
génotoxique celle de williams kroes et
monroe de cannes tox les versions
restent contradictoires sur la paternité
de l'article de cannes tox mais ce mémo
de monsanto datant de 2000 laisse
songeur un cadre haut placé remercie
plusieurs employés pour avoir colligé
les données mais aussi pour leur travail
d'écriture et de révision ainsi que
chemtox est une firme de relations
publiques pour leur multitude de
changements et de révision il évite les
employés à utiliser l'article pour
accroître les ventes du rand
moi
hélène semble répondre au traitement
elle aura droit à une nouveau répit ces
machines
moi je dis rémission je continue de me
battre et c'est moi qui va gagner et ce
trailer pour vous en parler croyez-moi
[Musique]
l'ancêtre d'intertek n'existe plus son
ancien président et fondateur et yonne
monroe est décédée d'un cancer en 2011
il a légué un million et demi de dollars
à son alma mater l'université mcgill de
montréal
la chaire de recherche en sécurité
alimentaire pour tous aujourd'hui son
nom
un mot en terminant pour vous dire que
des groupes qui s'opposent au glyphosate
ont déposé une poursuite en cour
fédérale pour contester la décision de
santé canada qui a prouvé le produit il
reproche à santé canada de ne pas avoir
fait appel à des experts indépendants
pour vraiment évaluer les impacts sur la
santé humaine
la semaine prochaine une émission
spéciale d' enquête sur la sphère snc
lavalin on remonte à l'origine de cette
crise
il s'agit du projet une enquête visant
la plus grande fraude de corruption
alors à terme de valeur monétaire pour
un contre obtenu le plus grand défaut de
corruption l'histoire du canada bien sûr
il y avait un processus d'appel d'offres
mais riadh ben aïssa savaient qu'ils
pouvaient court circuiter tout ça c'est
tout pour ce soir au nom de toute
l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
est revenu nous la semaine prochaine
pour une autre enquête
[Musique]